you got the project out you first of all
you dropped two projects this year right
yo caroline nacho i dropped kela knuckle
like soon as the
yeah it's like as soon as i dropped
caroline and i go to pandemic
it was crazy like i was i had so much
[ __ ] like lined up because i did a short
film
um i had like um the money bag yo tour
set up yeah
yeah yeah the baby toy was set up in my
own tour but as soon as it happened like
the pandemic
hit and it just said everything so much
live money taken away from everybody
so much live money especially someone
like baby who's about to have a crazy
festival run
for so yeah baby you know baby gonna
make that money regardless
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um so yeah i
mean i think that that's also a dope
thing is like
a lot of people have taken advantage of
the fact during the pandemic like and
just have been dropping even more music
than they usually would
because it's almost like you got to make
up for the lost bread like
why sit on the music people i feel like
now right now people are listening to
music more than ever and they're
listening to it differently if that
makes sense
exactly i guess they'll appreciate it
more and ain't nothing else to do but
make me